SPEAKER 1: All right.
So I've got a couple
questions over here.
If you have a question,
just line up over there.
I see a couple
people already there.
So go for it.
Take it away.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
This question's
probably for Guellermo,
but anybody else maybe if
they have some opinions too.
So I have a pretty
large application
which has users and communities
and things like that.
Once in awhile, a user will go
onto the page where it says,
like, list all the users in this
community which in the novice
sense emits a whole lot of get
XHR's like one for each user.
I've turned that into a batch
request to get all of them
at the same time.
But it still is going over
the regular HTTP connection.
But I also have Socket.IO
running for real time updates.
And I was thinking
about it earlier today.
I was wondering if it
made sense in any way
if the socket.IO connection was
actually websocket connection
to route some of
these XHR request
that would normally go through
the regular HitUp connection.
Is that a sort of thing
that would be stupid?
GUILLERMO RAUCH:
Yeah, definitely.
I've seen a lot of people-- I
mean, if you're using socket,
A, you're doing it right.
So definitely.
No, I've see a lot of people
do this HTTP over websocket.
I think when it comes out
to specific optimization
like the one you're
mentioning, there's
a lot of things to consider.
One of them is, if you're
making tons of XHR requests
in parallel, SPDY solves
this problem really well.
Because it allows you
to push resources.
It allows you to multiplex.
It also does compression.
So by turning on SPDY, you might
get an immediate win there.
The other thing to
consider is of course
on the other extreme, which
is ditching HTTP requests
and just requesting them through
some sort of event or RPC call
sorts.
So I think the thing that's most
important there kind of goes
back to what I was managing
earlier is on that page,
you sort of know what
requests are going to come.
And it's optimizing around that.
Maybe not so much optimizing
around the client requesting,
but the server sending without
a client requesting itself.
Does that make sense?
OK.
Anyone want to add something?
Maybe say definitely?
DAN SHAW: Definitely.
Yeah, and I Guillermo
touched on the point
that I was going to add
there that the routing
for the returned
responses could--
you could find a
lot of efficiency
by having those be routed back
to your app with socket.IO.
So you would have
response events and sort
of dynamic events all coming
through the same channel.
AUDIENCE: All right.
Probably for Erik and
Dan, excluding some
of the optimizations
that Trevor talked about,
I would like to know the ratio
of front end programmers who
become fully functional full
stack programmers versus
the more server side Java C++
.NET whatever sort of experts
who then become functional
front end people.
So it's the ratio
of one to the other.
DAN SHAW: Very complex question.
All right, so there's
two questions there.
The-- huh?
0%?
OK.
0%.
Present
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
DAN SHAW: No one needs
to be full stack.
I wanted to highlight
that on this panel here,
there are at least two
front end developers
who've become back developers.
And that would be
myself and Trevor.
TREVOR NORRIS: 50%.
DAN SHAW: 50%, right?
And then were you
back end first?
GUILLERMO RAUCH:
I don't remember.
DAN SHAW: Full stack.
GUILLERMO RAUCH: I was-- I
was front end and back end.
But Javascript got me
interested in, I think,
optimizing the
entire network stack.
And I think that's a cool
opportunity with Node.
You might start-- or
Javascript in general.
You might start with something
very, very front end based
and then do whatever
you want like control
a drone or [INAUDIBLE]
or write an entire OSTCP
stack in JavaScript.
So 0%.
AUDIENCE: Specifically for Erik,
within Paypal, you probably
have some data points
here-- front end people who
became serving their
own data versus people
who were responsible for serving
data becoming front end people.
ERIK TOTH: Yeah, it's
an interesting question.
I think first of all,
full stack changes
depending on where you go.
So when I think full stack,
I think front end developer.
I think web application
the-- what did you call it?
The back end of the front end?
The back front end engineer?
Front end back end engineer,
the mid tier engineer, and then
somebody that knows
database level stuff.
Like, that's full stack for me.
So if you break
it down that way,
I don't know that we have
any full-- we may have--
I don't think we have any
full stack engineers at Paypal
because we have a service
oriented architecture.
We intentionally
segment people to have
those disciplines on purpose.
That said, if you're really
talking about mid-tier
potentially, mid-tier,
or application
level engineers that have--
almost said graduated.
That's not the right
term-- but that embrace
front end engineering and
then front end engineers
that have embraced
application development.
I think it's-- I mean, it's kind
of an expectation that has been
set.
And most everyone has
made that transition.
One of the things that we
did during that transition
is we acknowledged that
maybe everyone doesn't
want to do this.
And that's OK.
And we moved that criteria
down so if you just
want to work on air
quotes back end,
then there's plenty of
mid-tier services, applications
that you can work on.
But if you want to work on
the front tier, that's great.
Really, all that is is
aggregating services,
aggregating data, and basically
transforming it into a format
that you can use-- plucking
off the values that
are important to
you and representing
that for front end consumption.
So I think we've had
really good success in it.
I don't know.
There's the whole, we
can reuse JavaScript
on the front end
of the back end.
I don't see that I've seen any
actual-- I don't see that I've
seen that in practice that's
actually added a ton of value.
But the fact that all
of our front engineers
understand async
programming with JavaScript
automatically put them a step
ahead when getting into Node
and understanding how
Node API works, APIs work,
how talking to services work,
and just the mental model
around working at the back
end of the front end tier.
I think we've seen really
good success with it just
from that perspective
specifically.
The corollary of seeing
Java engineers that
haven't necessarily
worked-- they
may have worked in futures.
They may have worked in
multi-threaded applications.
But to make that jump to async
development and not just,
like, higher order
functions or lambda like,
oh, I can pass functions around
and it looks async to actually
grokking and understanding
async development has been-- I'm
not going to say
it was a challenge.
But it wasn't is natural
from my experience.
That fair enough?
AUDIENCE: Right on.
DAN SHAW: Riffing on Erik's
talk, the great thing
about the way the stacks
evolved and Node and front end
JavaScript, It's really
given us opportunities
to be creative and sort of
solve-- we're engineers solving
the problems that we want to--
scratching the itches that we
have, solving those problems.
So we now can go and accomplish
those in new and unique ways.
So encouraging or
forcing engineers
to move one way or
the other I think
is the wrong way of
thinking about it.
Giving opportunities to grow
and expand your experience,
your knowledge
and understanding,
is what Node has provided.
And I think that's
really compelling.
AUDIENCE: Hello.
My question is more
about the hardware.
You mentioned in
your presentation
that you're able to reduce the
number of servers like half
while you had all your
application written in Java.
And you moved to
Node.js and were
able to reduce the
half for the server.
So my question is, what
is the optimal setup
of a server that you'll need?
Suppose you have like
one high end server,
like 128 gigabyte of RAM,
210 gigabit ethernet,
and like 40 CPUs.
So would you chop into
the virtual machines?
What is the optimal way so you
get the best performance, maybe
that sweet spot?
ERIK TOTH: I think the
question is predicated
on a comment I made, but I
think everybody can probably
chime in to this.
My very short answer is that
it has absolutely nothing
to do with the
hardware profile and it
has all to do with
how you design
the system and specifically
that application.
And the thing that I referenced,
the particular application,
the profile of that application,
was way more amenable to a Node
stack then it happened
to be for the JVM.
It wasn't necessarily
about the hardware profile.
It wasn't anything else.
It was that specific
app had-- the work
that it did just was
in Node's wheelhouse.
And the framework that
it ran on on the JVM
just was a square peg in a
round hole type of situation.
AUDIENCE: My question
mostly-- question
is that you know the
Node.jus uses one thread.
So it's better to dedicate
one CPU per virtual machine.
So then comes the
question, how much
RAM is it better to dedicate
to application server
and how much-- depending
maybe on the network or
TREVOR NORRIS: All right,
so to address that,
Node a single thread.
So the general rule of thumb
is, one Node process per core.
Given that you're
only running Node,
right, the V8 heap maxes
out at 1.5 gigs by default.
And so n cores times 2 is way
more RAM than you'll need.
So if you're running 40 cores
with more than 80 gigs of RAM,
you're going to be, like--
I mean, I hardly ever see
hard hit applications using more
than 800 megs of RAM, right?
So 40 cores and 60 gigs
of RAM should run you fine
if you're running
40 Node processes.
ERIK TOTH: Just a small,
like, editorial side
note-- if your application
runs on two boxes that
have 80 cores or
40 cores, you're
kind of setting yourself
up for failure in the sense
that if one of those boxes
goes down, you're kind of SOL.
So I think at least for
what we've experienced,
the optimum is actually
running more smaller boxes.
You're more resilient
to any outages
or any issues it may run.
So I think the, like, how do you
optimize gigantic hardware may
be answering the wrong
question in a way.
DAN SHAW: So I would
encourage you to not
think of your VMs as
just a single Node app.
You're setting yourself
up for a monolith.
So in each one of
your VMs, you may
have multiple apps,
multiple processes doing
and orchestrating
amongst themselves.
So unfortunately, it's
one of those sort of not
very satisfying, it depends.
But I would encourage
you not to think
of a single core,
single process,
let's slice it,
those 40 cores up
into a single process
in a single VM.
Two can work in some
of those situations.
But really looking at how each
individual deployment works
effectively will color
how that gets carved up.
And it'll probably
vary from application
to application what the most
optimal profile of your VMs
is going to look like.
AUDIENCE: Actually I
was most interested
in the ratio between the
network and the Rom memory.
So if you have,
like, good network,
if you want to keep a big
load on this one Node,
then how much--
TREVOR NORRIS: There is none.
AUDIENCE: Rom-- sorry?
TREVOR NORRIS: There's no ratio.
AUDIENCE: There is no ratio.
TREVOR NORRIS: It
completely depends
on the work you're doing.
If you're just
passing data through,
I mean, I'm not crapping you--
if you're just passing data
through on a Node app and you're
handling 10,000 connections
on the box, I see no processes
run under 100 megs of RAM,
right?
But if you're doing,
like, template rendering,
and you're doing the same
number of connections,
you could be using 800
to a gig of RAM, right?
There's no possible ratio
that is statistically
significant in terms of
how much bandwidth you have
and how much memory you need.
AUDIENCE: So best approach is
benchmarking before going live?
TREVOR NORRIS: Yes.
Yeah, you need to know
the limitations and use
case of your app to be
able to determine that.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: This question
is for Guillermo
and any other
member of the panel.
In your presentation,
the issue of real time
came up and really real time.
How you considered
setting real time
to, say, some common
denominator like 20 seconds
so that no matter where
you are in the world,
real time is always 20
seconds in the past?
GUILLERMO RAUCH: I was
going to include something
in this presentation, which
is the research by Nielsen
on how we react or
how long it takes
us to react to data changes.
And I think that's a
meaningful addition to how
we assess speed and real
timeness of applications.
It roughly goes like this.
If it's under 0.1
seconds, the user
has a feeling that he's
interacting directly
on the data.
This is the case when you
use Excel on a local machine.
Like, everything you
do is instantaneously.
You think you're
altering data directly.
And you sort of forget about
the persistence aspect of it.
And he says, under one
second to most human beings,
what happened was instantaneous.
That's why I advocate for not
showing spinners or loading
in the [INAUDIBLE] unless a
significant amount of time
has passed.
Because to most people, under
one second is instantaneous.
I've trained myself to
recognize that, for example,
my ps1 variable on batch
was taking too long.
And it was like 50
milliseconds off.
But most human beings that are
not staring at their terminals
all think under one second,
everything's instantaneous.
And then he says,
over 10 seconds,
that's a limit at which you lose
your attention span and you,
like, tab to something else.
You open Reddit or
twitch.tv and you just
do whatever-- you
do something else.
Or you--
DAN SHAW: [INAUDIBLE]
tablet's slowing down.
GUILLERMO RAUCH: Like, yeah.
When you guys were working
in the previous question,
I was somewhere else.
I'm just kidding.
So I think there's a
theoretical basis to how
we can assess, like, how real
time an application is, which
has to do with, OK,
so the server learns
of a change on the data.
How fast can we get it to users?
And that's why I was saying that
as long as your application is
self-updating and
fast, And it could
be fast just because
you're closer to server
and you're [INAUDIBLE] right?
Or even if the page was just
refreshing automatically,
if the right conditions
are set, your application
does feel real time.
So yeah, it would
go from that angle
to assess how real
time an application is.
But I found that the best way
to, like, define it has been,
it has to be fast.
And the user has to learn
of the changes to the data
without doing anything.
AUDIENCE: That's all fine for
the biomechanical implications
of a circuit, such as your
finger taps on something.
You feel it in your
brain and so on.
But if we're just talking
about setting the present
to 20 seconds in
the past, then you
could theoretically
bring everything
that happened on the
server down to the client
20 seconds in the past.
And then that
person would always
see the present as
it already happened.
GUILLERMO RAUCH: I
don't follow that.
AUDIENCE: So I--
we're all so tied up
into trying to get something
transferred from a server
to the client.
GUILLERMO RAUCH: Oh, you're
saying if the client doesn't
know the data has
changed, to them,
it doesn't matter
how fast they get it?
Is that--
AUDIENCE: They already have it.
It's already happened 20
seconds before they got it.
Before they even saw it,
they already received it.
GUILLERMO RAUCH: Maybe--
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] delay.
So, like, your stock
ticker, when you got it,
would be 20 second behind.
GUILLERMO RAUCH:
Like data sampling?
TREVOR NORRIS: OK.
So, yeah.
I've actually seen
this and I think
I know what you're saying
where it was actually updating
by the second what
was happening.
But when I looked the
code, what was happening
is that it was sending me
chunk five second updates
and then updating one second.
But technically, the data
was five seconds in the past.
But to me, it looked
instantaneous.
Is that what you're saying?
AUDIENCE: Yes.
TREVOR NORRIS: OK.
All right.
GUILLERMO RAUCH: All right.
So I think-- I think
that's important.
Because a lot of
what we talk about
is optimizing the
experience, right?
But I think the most important
optimization we can make
is have the power
to decide, right?
And that's what serverpush
allows us to do.
So even if we can
get away tricks
like that, if we
don't have serverpush,
we can't do the most optimal
way of sending data out.
Because we want to send it right
away after the server knows.
Maybe we don't.
But if we have the
right architecture,
we can make the choice, whereas
if you're stuck on some older
architectures, you can't.
But other than that, I
think that it's answered.
You want to add something?
AUDIENCE: So a couple years ago,
I went to a session on Node.js.
And they were talking about SSL
termination at the Node tier
and that one server failing
could take down or make
the entire cluster
compute bound.
And I wonder if
that's been addressed.
DAN SHAW: No.
So this is-- what
you're describing
is actually a very-- I know
the exact scenario that you're
talking about.
Because I lived in it in Voxer.
So that issue is
in part very, very
specific to Voxer's
architecture.
So in order to maintain the
rich, real time experience,
there's a lot of
session affinity.
So the fact there's
that session affinity,
all of the SSL termination and
all that, the SSL handshakes,
is very CPU intensive.
And so if you do tens
of thousands all at
the same time on a single
process and everybody
is coming back to
the exact same Node,
then you're going to
be in a world of hurt.
So that's a challenge
very specific
to that particular architecture.
But the SSL termination story
in Node is still not great.
We've made improvements
in what will be 12.
But it's incremental.
But typically in large
scale applications,
the SSL termination is
done off the process.
And if you look at the
proxies all way down story,
there's a reasonable argument
to be made if you don't need SSL
throughout your stack to do SSL
termination off the process.
Do you want to talk about some
of the SSL termination stuff
that you--
ERIK TOTH: [INAUDIBLE].
DAN SHAW: OK.
OK.
Let me let Erik talk about that.
ERIK TOTH: So, a prerequisite
for everything at Paypal,
obviously, is security.
So we do use SSL
all the way down.
We were proactive in
making the decision
that we don't do any SSL in
Node, partially because it
would be a performance
bottleneck for us.
But as much as it's
like a warm, we
love the Node community type of
this is how it operates thing,
it actually is true.
It's not a core competency
of our apps in the same way
that running cluster is not.
Like, understanding how
our deployments happen
is not a core
competency of our apps.
So, like, forcing
our apps to do SSL,
forcing our apps
to do GZIP, that's
not an application level thing.
That's a system and
infrastructure level saying.
So it's just work for us.
And I think Dan was alluding
to some other things
that we've had to do to
improve SSL performance
since we have an n
tier architecture
and doing SSL all the way down
is really expensive regardless
of your implementation.
But we've definitely
decided that those are not,
like, core features
that our apps need
to be concerned about.
So we've done everything
we can to pull them
into actual layers-- so
terminated engine x and then
reverse proxy into
Node for example.
Let things that do
are good at GZIP
do GZIP and not force that
through the Node pipeline.
GUILLERMO RAUCH:
Yeah, I was going
to add something
specifically because we do it
in the same way at
cloud up in Automatic.
Even from a modularity
perspective,
it makes more sense to always
consider your applications
just vanilla HTTP server.
And even if you decided
to handle SSL in Node,
it would make more sense to
stack it with other modules
or processes and
wrap those servers.
So in our case, we
do with Engine X.
But if Node becomes
better at it or we just
want to do it in Node, we could.
But your application
should just export
lowest common denominator,
which would be just listening
on some port and
exposing just HTTP.